[Musique]
nous avons choisi l'emplacement du camp
4 au bord de l'immense entonnoir de nous
pourront déboucher va les pentes
supérieures c'est la corvée habituel
creusé la neige pour faire une
plateforme monter la tente
la bande cercueil dit lachenal où nous
passons de si mauvaise nuit après c'est
pas l'altitude assourdis par le vent et
le bruit des avalanches
au matin nous en faisant le show
surgelés raid comme du bois
malgré leurs guêtres de protection le de
la grille règne encore en maître sur
l'horizon
[Musique]
nous n'avons plus un instant à perdre en
quartier qui connaît bien l'himalaya
fait la grimace
un peu plus tôt chaque jour les nuages
sont là la victoire que nous chantons à
notre portée tiens à quelques heures de
beau temps
nous approchons du moment attendu depuis
des mois une intense surexcitation nous
gagnons tous nos efforts n'aboutiront
tilquin échec à quelques heures du but
plus nous nous élevons ait pu nous
sommes aveuglés par les tourbillons de
neige soulevée par le vent il faut
contourner dimanche crevasse
à chaque pas nous enfonçons jusqu'à mes
jambes
le pénétrons dans un monde étrange
qui n'appartient presque déjà plus à la
terre et le 3 juin 1950 à l'aube ils
partent pour le sommet où louis lachenal
peut prendre à 8000 75 mètres d'altitude
cette photo qui étonna le monde
la cour n'a était le premier sommet de
plus de 8000 mètres vaincu par l'homme
alors commence la longue la très longue
descente ces sommes cruellement marqués
dans leur chair peuvent à peine se tenir
debout
maurice herzog avance le premier il
marche très droit commun ottomane il a
les pieds et les mains gelées
lionel perret ensuite celui que les
sherpas ans surnommé le strong saïb
l'homme fort doit être conduit comme un
enfant la réverbération de la neige lui
a brûlé les yeux
[Musique]
voici louis lachenal portant lui aussi
un bandeau pour couvrir ses yeux
douloureux il a aussi les pieds gelés
[Musique]
gaston rebuffat souffrent également
ses blessures sont moins graves mais il
doit être étendu sur un traîneau
alors seulement lé vainqueur de
l'anapurna essaye de raconter ce qu'ont
été ces trois terribles journées lors
d'un effort dans la tempête pour
retrouver le camp 4 le froid terrible
l'avalanche qui les recouvre
et au moment où tout espoir semblait
perdu l'éclaircie miraculeuse qui a
permis à chacun de les apercevoir
pour ces hommes qui sont allés à la
limite de leurs forces
pas le temps de prendre le moindre repos
il faut redescendre le plus vite
possible vers le camp un car le mauvais
temps mena auparavant le docteur se
penche vers ce que le gel a le plus
touché lachenal devra subir l'amputation
de tous ses orteils quant à maurice
herzog
non seulement il perdra l'extrémité de
ses pieds mais encore la presque
totalité de ses doigts avec un courage
admirable
il supporte de tous les deux les
premières amputation que le docteur doit
effectuer en plein air
c'est dans ces conditions presque
inhumaine que va se dérouler la descend
une descente qui durera cinq semaines
oui trente cinq jours à dos d'homme les
pieds et les mains gelées tout obstacle
naturel étant dans ces circonstances
dramatiques un gigantesque problème
les torrents notamment les torrents
grossi par la fonte des neiges les
premières pluies de la mousson sont à
peine franchie sap sur des ponts de
fortune qui quelques minutes après le
passage de l'expédition seront emportés
par le courant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
huile mètres plus bas il faut encore
monter et gravir les contreforts des
1000 kerry
[Musique]
oh
l'équilibré est devenue très précaire
sur ce sol raviné par les pluies et la
charge humaine que transportent les
sherpas n'arrange pas les choses
[Musique]
il faut tailler au piolet une place pour
chaque pied tandis que la pluies de la
mousson gifle inlassablement le visage
des blessés qui se rendent très bien
compte que le moindre faux pas de leurs
porteurs pourrait leur être fatal
[Musique]
où
mon
pourtant déjà louis lachenal et maurice
herzog parle de l'avenir et pour la
première fois un pâle sourire apparaît
sur le visage de maurice herzog un
sherpa aide à boire il ne veut pas
penser à toutes les épreuves qui
l'attendent encore les mois d'hôpital
les nouvelles souffrances
douze années ont passé amputé de ses
doigts
maurice herzog a réappris à écrire et
c'est de sa main qu'ils signent les
nombreux documents qui lui sont soumis
au commissariat à la jeunesse et aux
sports rue de châteaudun
[Musique]
oh
ces rares moments de loisirs ils les
occupent en sportif
[Musique]
e
à
l'une de ses plus grandes joies et de se
rendre à l'aérodrome de guyancourt dit
vêtir la combinaison bleue de pilotes et
de s'envoler aux commandes de son stand
[Musique]
m
par la voie des airs il n'est en effet
qu'à quelques minutes de ces montagnes
des alpes françaises qu'il aime tant et
qu'il retrouve toujours avec le même
plaisir
[Musique]
m
malgré les mutilations qu'il a dû subir
il a toujours continué à pratiquer son
sport préféré
après l'alpinisme c'est à dire le ski
[Musique]
et
telle est l'homme de qui dépend le sport
français
celui qui est à l'origine des succès
flatteur de ces deux dernières années
mais quand on lui en fait la remarque
en homme modeste il s'en défend
le mérite en revient en premier lieu à
mon avis aux athlètes qui se sont
dépensés sans compter
au cours de la saison écoulée et qui
nous ont apporté des performances dont
nous sommes aujourd'hui à juste titre
satisfait mais il ne faut pas oublier
que j'ai été beaucoup aidé dans cette
tâche qui a été la mienne depuis quatre
ans il a fallu trouver beaucoup d'argent
on me l'a donné il faudra continuer mais
surtout ce qu'il fallait créer c'est un
état d'esprit nouveau créer une
atmosphère jeune dynamique qui plaisent
à tous nos sportifs à tous nos athlètes
et aussi à tous nos dirigeants et je
crois que peut-être dans une certaine
mesure le fait que je sois moi-même un
sportif a pu avoir quelque influence sur
l'ensemble de tous mes collègues de tous
mes camarades et de tous mes amis qui
tous les dimanches se distribuent sur
tous les stades de france et du monde
pour apporter à la france quelques
succès supplémentaires
[Musique]